تمر احلام مهرجان سنوي تستضيفه الاحساء
شرق السعوديه للمره الثانيه
المهرجان شهد اقبالا كبيرا في ايامه
الاولى يضم عده فعاليات متعدده تحاكي
الاهتماما بالنخله والتمور ويجسد المهرجان
اربعين حرفه يدويه تعرف بها الاحساء فضلا
عن دعم الجانب التسويقي لتمور الاحسن
الاحساء ينضم الينا مراسل العربيه عبد
الرحمن العصيمي حياك الله عبد الرحمن
الجديد كيف يختلف المهرجان هذه السنه
نعم خالد فعلا يقبل كبير جدا ربما اليوم
ويوم الجمعه فيعتبر يعني اجازه نهايه
الاسبوع في الاقبال الكبير جدا منذ ساعات
العصر الاولى بعد صلاه العصر مباشره طبعا
هذا المهرجان ياتي بنسخته الثامنه ويحقق
نجاحات متتاليه حقيقه واعداد كبيره من
الزوار الحديث اكثر عن هذا المهرجان ينضم
اليه الاستاذ خالد بوشل المتحدث الرسمي بس
امانه الاحساء خالد اولا خلينا نتكلم عن
مصطلح التمور المصنعه ماذا نعني بالتمر
المصنعه تمور المصنعه في طبيعه تمور
الاحساء تكون تدخل دائره ايش يعني التصنيع
تكون مكنسه تكون محوله الى صناعات اخرى
كالمعامير عادت تمور الحساوي ما تؤكل مثلا
بل تدخل في مراحل تصنيعيه فلذلك في شهر
تسعه يتم التمور في هذا في شهر بدايه
السنه يتم عمل هذا المهرجان الكبير لك
التمريه الحساويه ماذا يحمل هذا المره جاب
مستطيل ثامنه همم شيء مختلف عن النسخ
الماضيه اخوي عبد الرحمن احنا بدانا يعني
مهرجان التمور في
2014 بدينا في 20 ركن الان لما نتكلم عن
60 ركن مشارك فاحنا وضعنا هدف وهو هدف
التصاعديه في عمليه الانتاج تحويل منتج
التمور الشعبي البسيط الى منتج اقتصادي
عالمي وهذا ما حققناه على مدار ثمان سنوات
لكن مترقبين هذا العام ان يحقق المهرجان
قفزات اقتصاديه همم نظير
التنافسيه الموجوده ما بين التجار في
عمليه تقديم قوارب جديده دخول التمر في
يعني في صناعات تحويديه همم يعني ابتكاريه
جديده
استقبال كبير من التجار ومن اصحاب المزارع
مهرجان العام الماضي السنه هذه ايضا العدد
كبير كما كان العمل الماضي
حققنا بكل جداره ولاول مره حققنا 700,000
زائر لكن هذا العام توسعنا في عمليه
الاركان توسعنا في عمليه المكان لان
متوقعين همم زياده عدد الزوار ومتى كما
تشاهدون اليوم احنا اليوم تونا في البدايه
في ثاني يوم والاقبال متزايد وهناك حضور
حتى من دول الخليج هايستمر الى متى هذا
المهرجان ان شاء الله باذن الله 36 يوم
يعني راح نتواصل حتى ما بعد يوم التاسيس
باذن الله تعالى جميل همم السنه هذه ايضا
في جهات حكوميه مشاركه وفي ايضا جهات اخرى
نتكلم عنها
نتكلم عن مهرجان ويتمر احلى نتكلم عن عرس
ثقافي واجتماعي جميل هناك الجهات الحكوميه
المشاركه التي هي يعني همم ما لها علاقه
في في عمليه
تصنيع التمور والنخيل همم يعني همم
الاضافه الى الى يعني ما هو يقدم خدمات
النخيل
والتمور للزوار شكرا جزيلا استاذ خالد
بوشل كنت معنا متحده الرسمي باسم امانه
الاحساء خالد يعني زي ما احنا شايفين
يقبال كبير صراحه وانواع كثيره من التمور
سواء التمور المصنعه المكنوزه المشتقات
التمور الكليجه بالتمر المعمول بالتمر دبس
التمر فمنتجات كثيره صراحه